straight ahead on Law and crime daily a
sex offender is accused of killing a
ten-year-old girl and dumping her body
leaving family members to deal with the
devastating aftermath he was like well I
just woke up and she's gone
his own son called to testify and forced
to withstand a sometimes heated
cross-examination
you were there when she was killed or
you weren't our legal analysts are
breaking down the testimony so far in
the Henry Dinkins trial as a judge
here's evidence that could put the
defendant away for Life law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
foreign
daily I'm Jesse Weber we heard detailed
and sometimes emotional testimony Monday
in the case of Henry Dinkins he's the
man accused of killing a young girl
breesia Terrell and her brother were
staying with Dinkins and his girlfriend
Andrea overnight in Davenport Iowa in
2020 and at some point it is believed
that Dinkins took priasia from the
apartment and killed her her
disappearance prompted a massive search
but her remains weren't found until
nearly a year after she was reported
missing when fishermen spotted her body
in a pond about 25 miles away from
Davenport in March of 2021. now at the
time Dinkins was locked up in an
unrelated charge but it turns out he's a
sex offender who had been released early
from prison but was required to register
and when he didn't do that police
arrested him when briegia's remains were
found they charged him with kidnapping
and murder raja's brother who is now 11
years old was called To The Stand Friday
and Monday to talk about the night that
Brian went missing and what he saw in
the hours after that but on
cross-examination his stories didn't
seem to match up
how was your relationship with her great
uh were the two of you close yes
how close really close
what were Henry and Andrea doing on the
bed
watching her
watching Brie yeah
did you find that weird
yes
why
because I was in the living room alone
they were in the back room
Point did Henry come back to that
apartment
he had a white shirt on and some shorts
a little weird when he came back to the
apartment that first time you saw him
did you see Bree with him no
was it at that point that you started to
cry yes why are we crying because she
wasn't there
when you say she who are you talking
about my sister either you were there
when she was killed or you weren't
I said I guess
I don't accept that answer sure either
you were there when she was shot or you
weren't
I was there damn
so you were there
yes you saw your dad shoot bridge at
Terrell yes okay not we didn't say that
when the prosecutor asked you
because it's not the truth right
everything I say is true all right I
want to bring in my co-host legal
analyst Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Terry I'm going to start with you that
part is confusing to me why when he was
on direct and being asked by the
prosecution why didn't they ask him did
you see the defendant shoot your sister
he wasn't asked that question then the
defense questions about it how come he
didn't bring it up can you clarify what
happened here I really think the
prosecution should have asked that very
question remember we're in front of a
judge not a jury but I do think it would
have helped to clarify the sequence of
events even with the judge I think she
did not ask that question because she
didn't want to upset DL is what they're
calling him a deterriss but that's the
biggest point of this question did the
defendant kill the victim I agree but
she was trying to establish the timeline
she established that he was there she
established that he poured bleach in a
bush she established that you know all
of these things leading up to it but she
didn't ask that direct question and part
of the reason on redirect we find out
that he didn't want to talk about it
that he was afraid he was eight at the
time so he didn't initially tell the
police at one point he did tell the
police she didn't ask on Direct he
mentioned it on Cross she mentioned it
again on redirect so he does say that he
saw his father actually shoot in fact
the father's girlfriend was there as
well it feels like his credibility has
called into questions I mean
significantly and that's what the
defense is doing I know it should be a
lot better if there's a jury there
because he's going to add a little bit
more theatrics but I think even for the
judge and like I tell most people when
they're arguing in front of a court it's
not just the judge in front of you it's
also the Appellate judge as well you
made this argument say no one in their
right mind should credit this witness's
testimony because if you can lie about
this major issue as you're as you're
hinting at how are you telling the truth
about anything else especially when
you're talking about your father's
reaction when he comes back into the
home without briation and his testimony
though about the Dinkins strange
Behavior after when he came home was a
little weird right that hurts the
defendant oh I think it definitely hurts
the defendant he wants to prove prove
that his father did it because he knows
that the father left the house and he
didn't come back with her he knows that
this happened and no one else could have
done it so the defendant absolutely is
acting like I have no idea she just
disappeared and the brother knows better
all right well we're going to continue
this discussion because I think this is
a fascinating case and really
interesting witness but still had a long
crime daily or coverage of testimony in
the Henry Jenkins trial will continue
to the true teller you know I'm very
caring
she helped out a lot you know secondary
mom in the house but most of her she was
real good
what the victim's mother said on the
stand as she recalled the day her only
daughter was reported missing
[Music]
and welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody we're taking a look at the
testimony in the Henry Dinkins trial
Dinkins is accused of kidnapping and
killing a 10 year old girl in Iowa back
in 2020. brija Terrell was the
half-sister of dinkin's son they had the
same mother Aisha Langford testified
about her children in court on Monday
and she confirmed that Brie Asia and her
brother referred to as DL had an
impromptu sleepover at the apartment
that dinkin shared with his girlfriend
prosecutors say sometime during the
night Dinkins took briasia from the
apartment and killed her her body was
found by fishermen in a pond almost a
year later brazier's mother Aisha
Langford testified on Monday about the
initial reports that Dinkins couldn't
find briasia and the search by police
I noticed Mr Dinkins Impala flying down
the opposite way
making a really hard turn on I think
it's a left turn on E string okay
okay what type of vehicle was he driving
he was driving in a maroon Impala with
tinted windows okay
okay um and then did you pass him when
you saw him heading east yes and what
did you do I made a u-turn and then at
that point in time it described what she
did I was beating behind him honking the
horn I was calling his phone and when I
finally got him on the phone he said
that he was headed to
Jersey metals because they wanted to
talk to him out there and I was still on
this bumper honking the horn and we had
pulled over by the McDonald's do you
recognize the depictions in those
photographs I do how do you recognize
I recognized it because those were
photos that was shown to me to try to
identify if that was a a flip-flop that
was that might have been hers okay
describe what happened when you were
shown those photographs
um they had told me and it wasn't hers
and they had walked off and it was
already dark time and I just fell out
because I'm like dang I can't go in we
can't stop looking for she's still out
there I can't go in and I just fell out
okay okay I want to start with you Brian
on this because the big issue that I see
is the fact that she basically let her
daughter be with Dinkins we can't escape
the fact that he's a registered sex
offender that factor is that going to
help the defense daughter and son right
both of the children because this is the
mother that that connects the two of
them and so I think it leads to the
defense there's a lot of bad facts that
she's putting out there but for me I
would at least say but regardless of
what his background is and and what he's
accused of prior to this you trusted him
enough to leave him not with one but
with both of your children I would
always bring it back there because at
least at some point in time because at
least at some point you've got to ask
why would he do this why would he watch
the two children to take one and go
murder them I think from this witness
you could probably try to get a counter
balancing effect of saying yeah but no
you believed that he was safe with these
children why did you leave them with him
but how many times do we cover cases
where fathers and mothers kill their
children out of nowhere it shocks the
conscience it shocks everybody so it
might not play that much even if she
left the children with them at the same
time he could be capable of doing this
look the defense was definitely trying
to say it was her fault she should have
known better she wasn't a good mom she
didn't take care of the kids the way she
should but I think they established on
the redirect and on Direct frankly she's
a good mom she thought that he was fine
the children had gone with him before
both of them now remember this is dl's
father and it's free Asia's stepdad and
he actually had been in the home before
for a few months before he left the home
so everyone knows who he is and I don't
think they established well enough that
the mother knew he was a sex offender
yes he'd been in jail but she didn't
know the details of that and in fact the
grandmother was the one who let the
children go so she wouldn't have done it
if she had known that that's what she
said we also talked about the fact this
is in front of a judge not a jury it's a
bench trial the sex offender aspect
we've talked about it before when a
judge looks at this factor and whether
or not the mother you know should have
left the the children with him and
whether or not she knew he was a sex
offender how much do you think that part
is going to affect the judge's
determination I'm a little jaded as a
defense attorney the law would suggest
that a judge who have seen many cases
like this before not just up to trial
but also in negotiation look at it says
he was 17 and according to the
allegations he was with someone who was
under 10. now he's in his 50s this is
not a sexual uh registration case where
he did it five years ago to someone this
age that's not a pattern between the
registration and this charge I'd hope
the judge would separate the two all
right well I think this is a fascinating
case and I really don't know which way
it's going to go but I'll tell you what
we have a lot more to cover